what's up y'all it's the movie
retrospective
doing some 80s [ __ ] again doing some
comic book movies but maybe not the one
that you're uh thinking of
so this is swamp thing from 1982. yeah
now i remembered it yeah honestly i
hadn't seen this movie for a really long
time probably since the early to mid 80s
i don't i didn't see it in the theater
but i'm pretty sure i saw it on cable
and i remember like liking it but
not being one that was really in my
regular rotation i guess
so i was actually really curious to
watch it again and do you know i had
completely and utterly forgotten that
this [ __ ] was directed by wes [ __ ]
craven yeah i totally forgot about that
but you know what i mean so uh how he
got involved with it and actually
at the time i think he was probably
sorry that he got involved with it like
afterward because it really didn't do
all that well
at the theater
but uh you know he was kind of more
known for doing obviously real gritty
horror right he'd done last house on the
left and hills have eyes and all that
and i guess he kind of wanted to show
like the larger hollywood studios that
he could deal with
sort of like an action movie with
comedic elements like he wanted to show
i guess that he wasn't just like a
one-trick pony
now he had done deadly blessing prior to
this like in 1981
and when they called him to do swamp
thing
it's funny because wes craven i don't
know if you know he's talked about this
in a few of his interviews but he was
brought up in a very strict
fundamentalist christian household
and was not allowed to read comic books
so he had never i mean when he was a kid
he never saw horror movies and he you
know so it so he didn't know anything
about the swamp thing character but i
guess he kind of liked it so he came on
board one of the guys that was producing
it i saw an interview with him earlier
named michael usland this was actually
his first kind of big production thing
as a kid he had grown up being really
into dc comics particularly batman
and he was sad when he was a kid that
the only batman that we had was kind of
the campy you know the campy batman tv
series yeah uh he thought that you know
superheroes should be taken more
seriously he was imagining the dark
knight which a lot of dudes were yeah
you know what i mean yeah uh so he was
so he kind of wanted to
uh he did actually buy the rights to
batman uh when you know when that wasn't
all that expensive
and uh so initially he wanted to do
something with batman but then he was
like well that's gonna cost like way too
much to you know get his vision across
so he decided to go with a lesser-known
dc comics character swamp thing yeah let
me say something about batman
this is a personal experience that we i
had
when i was in high school living up in
michigan we'd get up [ __ ]
this is 80s you know i think it must be
around 85.
uh it was before
the uh
uh batman movie came out the uh the one
with uh jack nicholson who decorate who
directed what the tim burton tim burton
it was before that one actually came out
but not much before like maybe a few
months before though
and me and other guys are sitting up
there sitting in denny's drinking coffee
in the middle of the [ __ ] night you
know because it was safe to go there
when you were kids your parents let you
i guess you know
and uh
bitching about why [ __ ] why there
wasn't a good batman
that batman should have been like the
comic books and there was a comic books
around that time called the dark knight
and you know batman was awesome he was
kind of like the [ __ ] the punisher
and eventually we got something kind of
like that you know the the tim burton
one was
pretty good
but the ones that came later were a lot
better that's what we were imagining
back then
well apparently you weren't alone
because a lot of people did
you know and as i said i mean superman
the first superman was obviously showed
that superheroes could be taken more
seriously right first too but uh so far
that hadn't really been done for batman
and like i said um you know because
michael usland he wanted to do batman
but he just thought he wouldn't be able
since he was new at it he wouldn't be
able to get the budget to
do what he wanted to do so he decided to
go with a lesser-known dc character
swamp thing yeah we were taking them
serious when we were kids just yeah
given that to us yet that came later
one of the first real serious ones after
batman there's after superman that i saw
that i said was hey that's kind of
serious i like was dark man and i don't
know if there was a comic book
associated with that
but it felt like a comic book
movie i don't know either but you know
what's weird man was good is that i
think there's like some there's some
similarities in this and swamp thing
there's some stuff that happens in this
movie that's similar to stuff that
happened in dark man i'm not sure either
like if dark man came from because the
swamp thing comic
um the character of swamp thing first
came like first uh emerged in 1971
yeah i think in maybe like another comic
and then like he had his own later on
yeah
i was mentioning that when me and jane
were watching i was like this is kind of
like dark man yeah it reminded me a lot
of dark man it is kind of a serious
comic book movie serious for the time
you know what i mean yeah it's still
pretty it's still kind of goofy right
gotta say but it was a big move up
compared to like a lot of the other
super yeah [ __ ] later on spawn came
out we [ __ ] loved that but this was
way before the spawn all right this is
there i really with this movie there's
only two problems i have with this movie
swamp thing didn't look like the swamp
thing
he does but he kind of looks i saw this
once too human in this yeah well like i
said they i think the budget on this was
only maybe two and a half million
um you know and honestly the producers
were kind of like breathing down wes
craven's neck he had to cut a lot of
stuff out that he wanted to do because
it was too expensive
uh so they didn't really have a [ __ ] ton
of money to work with the suits and i
think that the main criticism that
people uh level toward this is that it
suffers from quote unquote man in suit
syndrome yeah where it just looks like a
dude in a suit the the swamp thing suit
is not bad um not terrible like i said
it doesn't look like
the comic book necessarily it kind of
looks like i saw another review of this
earlier that said it actually looks like
somebody dressing up as him like for
cosplay but he couldn't really afford to
do a good one it kind of looks like that
the comic book covers the swamp thing he
looked like sigma in the [ __ ] sea
monster that's what he looks like i mean
he still looks like a person but he has
like all these kind of like palm fronds
like sticking out like that he still
looks like a big like a hulk type person
but he still looks like a human but he
has like a lot more detail a lot more
plant matter on him and then the super
here the uh the um the super villain in
this [ __ ] looks like [ __ ] i mean
that's a good idea but it was a good
idea but it just looks like that's the
worst i have to say i mean it looks
really bad they had people out there
that could make really bad they could
make badass
costumes and
you know really they should have got the
guy who who did [ __ ] like the howling
the guys who did the howling i said yeah
should have done the costumes was that
didn't rob boutin do that
they could have executed kind of like a
pig version of or a wild boar version of
kind of like the
the the werewolves from from um the
howling and it would have been a lot
better
i was not entirely sure can i just say
this i was not entirely sure
what
the arcane monster was supposed to be
even
i thought because you remember that
scene like near the beginning of swamp
thing where
uh ray wise like the the doctor genius
guy is digging around in the tank and
then he pulls that little critter out
yeah that's a possum which is like yeah
it's like a possum
so i thought because they were talking
about this possum being like part of the
experiment because you know the serum is
supposed to mingle plant and animal dna
for you know which that can of course
that's never going to go wrong but you
know what i mean so they had that so i
thought that the arcane monster was
maybe supposed to be like
i was like was it trying to harken back
to the possum because i was like what
animal is he supposed to be exactly and
he didn't really have any plant i didn't
i wasn't reading plant
i was a wild boar
yeah i was more yeah i was more reading
like pig head but with
like a mane but then what what what was
going on with the rest of the suit
though i couldn't figure out they have a
tail see i don't think it did
and the thing about it though is that he
wasn't just like a pig man with hair
like i don't know what that was about
but
he also like
at first he kind of like started he
didn't melt exactly but he kind of
almost looked like he was developing a
cocoon of some kind and he looked like a
big turd yeah and then like he busted
out of the turd
and then he was a pig monster or
something
i didn't really get amorphous
i know but the thing about it i mean the
whole it didn't make any sense it wasn't
a good creature really it wasn't and and
honestly and it should have at least
tied in with like the theme of the
because you know it and we'll talk about
the plot in a little bit uh too but the
whole point of the serum
was that it makes you
more of what you already are yeah and i
was like i didn't get that with the
arcane monster i'm like so what does
that mean that he what i would have
thought pig i don't know i guess
too much into it it's he read well
that's how that's what i do because what
it was is that they should but they
should have thought more about it is
what i'm saying they're like get that
get this movie in the can yeah that's
all they're thinking about you know
in this era they did not think too
too clearly
about things like that usually i mean
good movies did but most of them really
didn't it was just trying to get the
just trying to get a monster out there
get the movie done and
let [ __ ] kids figure out figure it
out or make [ __ ] up about it they didn't
really care oh you want a monster yeah
he's a monster yeah that's that's that's
as far as that [ __ ] i will say that the
monster the the arcane monster didn't
look as bad as rawhead rex but almost it
actually kind of reminded me it was it
kind of reminded me well
it kind of reminded me of the rawhide
monster it was it was worse right
yeah rawhead rex was i think the rodhead
rex monster i think that that threw me
off because it just had those big googly
eyes when raw head rex came out we got
that [ __ ] on vhs when it was new and we
[ __ ] enjoyed the movie we were like
yeah but mostly we just like the damn
church scenes with the [ __ ] priest
and he was getting pissed off by the
monster and the and the evil [ __ ] the
evil stained glass window we just
thought that [ __ ] was cool and then when
you saw the milestone you know we were
like yeah okay
we didn't question it that much you know
i guess you could say we're kind of like
it was the 80s the 80s weren't that
different from the 50s i guess well i
mean the 80s like a lot you would let a
lot of stuff slide as long as somebody
and honestly the first time i saw swamp
thing it didn't occur to me that like
the m and like i said the swamp thing
monster looks okay yeah um you know but
the the evil monster at the end at least
it's only at the end like it doesn't
really look all that good it doesn't
seem all that well thought out
um but yeah so did some random [ __ ]
what it was is they cheaped out they
didn't get the right people
to make those
or like i said maybe they just ran out
of money because like i said they made
this for only 2.5 million
and wes craven said that the producers
were huge dicks and that they were just
constantly like on their asses all the
time you have to cut this you have to
cut that you know this is costing too
much blah blah blah so
i kind of feel like the arcane monster
they made it out of whatever like
remnants they had like hanging around
in the creature shop you can put that on
the producers then because you don't you
don't do a sci-fi or comic book movie
unless you have enough money to at least
get good costumes
if you don't can't afford good costumes
you don't do that [ __ ] you do something
else and i mean that's kind of like the
whole
you know this is a monster movie yeah
you better have the monster you're
pretty much a superhero and the monster
in this one
i mean you know the good monster swamp
thing you see him a lot and you see him
in broad daylight
a lot so he had guys that could make
good creatures and creatures effects for
not that much money i mean that was a
kid that made the damn predator and they
hired him a second unit to come in and
fix the [ __ ] that they had on there
before which he was just some kid in
late teens early 20s and he didn't
charge that much to make that predator
just he wanted to make it i think he
made most of it his garage didn't he he
had that's what i heard garage studio i
mean he was good at latex he could model
and sculpt
but it's more talent than money really
you just got to get the right guys and
the problem is that the right once you
get the right guys once he's got a name
he wants to charge a [ __ ] ton of money
well rightly so people fighting over him
so yeah all these damn projects
but they should have went for
some
new guy who wanted to show off his
skills and you hire him to make the damn
costumes and it wouldn't would but i
could beat those costumes i'm pretty
good i'm with my hands but i could
definitely make better costumes than
that well i could for sure make a better
one than the arcane monster in this i'm
pretty i'm pretty confident i'm pretty
confident
that it would have been easy to beat i
think i could have done
the swamp thing the swamp thing i could
have done a better version of the swamp
thing
yeah i could make that costume mine
would look a little bit more like sigma
than a sea monster that would look like
the ones it looked like the cover of the
comic books yeah they should have made
them like you know the red eyes you know
that'd been cool if they had made him
like
like goopier like with more kind of
stuff hanging on him yeah but well he's
like a shambling mound of stuff is what
what swamp thing actually looked like i
mean i that's understandable like i said
because he did have to do like a lot of
stunts and fighting and [ __ ] like that
and where they shot this was hot as
balls yeah so uh i'm imagining
that yeah
you didn't have to show its skin the
comic book is just a shambling mound of
stuff so really you can make basically a
gilly suit that's what we would call it
in the army a ghillie suit which is a
damn jumpsuit with a bunch of burlap
straps hanging from it's all spray
painted different colors i just do with
different materials and have things like
[ __ ] like it looked in the comic book
lily pads and [ __ ] tentacles and
pieces of damn grass he looked like he
was growing you know it looked like he
looked like a plant well he was he was a
plant plant man he was a big bull
he'd be plant man i would do it along
the lines of a ghillie suit
yeah i mean and that
probably wouldn't have been uh that hard
to do but yeah i heard that like even
the stunt man that played the arcane
monster in this like at least fainted at
least one time because it was so [ __ ]
hot now even though the movie was
supposed supposed to be set in the
swamps of louisiana they actually shot
that in the swamps of south carolina
yeah so uh but it it looks like
louisiana though it kind of kind of
some of the trees of this it looks
swampy that's for sure look swampy just
not as thick as louisiana louisiana
swamp it's got a [ __ ] canopy over
it's real dark
real dark in there
yeah i'm sure it's darker i mean i don't
know if it was cheaper to film inside of
south carolina but i'm assuming it
probably was yeah so okay so let's talk
about uh the story for this so what you
have at the beginning you have the foxy
adrian barbeau in this and both of her
boobs
yeah let's let's talk about that for a
second because
we watched this on toby it's on 2b for
free yeah
and it says it's rated pg
and i'm watching the movie and i'm like
this has a lot of nudity for a pg but i
found out there's a reason for that okay
reason was
adrian barbow uh shot full frontal
nudity
not for the u.s cut for the european cut
okay uh there were also a couple of
other scenes that were supposed to be
only in the european cut like the whole
eyes wide shut party they were having
with the stripper and everything
um so those were only supposed to be in
the european one but when they put the
dvd out in the u.s they accidentally put
out the european one with all the
titties in it yeah and then this woman
in dallas texas
rented the movie for her kids and
complained at all the boobies
so they tried to recall it and fix it
yeah uh or actually the first thing they
tried to do they try to take the easy
way out and like ask adrian barbo hey
can you sign off on the american nudity
and she was like no that's not my
contract she's like i only did the
nudity for the european market because
the europeans love their boobies yeah
and so uh but it as it is now i guess
they just like said [ __ ] it and either
upped up the rating to pg13 i'm not
entirely sure what they did because like
i said we watched it on 2b and it still
says that the ratings pg-13 but all the
nudity is in there it's in the europe
it's the european cut the international
cut it's ridiculous because there's
nothing wrong with it it's just no i
know it's just funny that it's just
topless it's no big deal well and it's
like super gratuitous which is like
what's really funny about it well that's
what it's supposed to be yeah it's like
because in the american cut you can
still see like the side boob
because there's like a shot of her like
from the side but then she turns to the
front she's like hey boobies and
everything like that i was like oh my
god that's hilarious adrian barbell was
known for for for her well yeah you know
her cans all right
but
in in the u.s you didn't really see them
it was just you know she was just in
outfits
in this movie you do you get a big
steaming eyeful
me being an avid bubologist
professor of boobology
i always thought they were implants
but uh no they're natural yeah seeing
them uh without a bra yes right and she
she's let's just say you know she's
talented she's very gifted um
not as big as i thought they were going
to be but it's most she she looks better
in a bra if you ask me
she looks better in her bra that she
looks bigger in a bra wow tough crowd
hey
you know
in her era
well actually no because they had
massive implants in that era too yeah
they did just uh
yeah no she i think she just she looks a
lot bigger in a in a bra
well she's good though most ladies do
it's probably like a c cup
most ladies yeah but yeah so if if you
ever want to see adrian barbo's actual
boobs uh you know yeah live and in color
uh this here is the movie to see him
uh because the version that's on 2b is
the european cut so you get to see the
full frontal nudity yeah so she's
looking good especially for her age
she's not a young woman in this i would
say she's pushing 40. i don't know
though because i mean this was only 82.
uh she'd only she'd been in the uh she
was in the fog the year before this she
was in
uh escape from new york the year before
this so this is year before that okay no
this was the year after escape from new
york okay when did the fog come out 1980
all right so she okay this is two years
after the fog
and she was also in creep show this same
year yeah so she had been in her 30s so
yeah you know what i mean um so she
plays a character named alice cable
now alice cable is actually not a
character from the comic book she's a um
a conglomeration
in the comic books there was a guy named
matt cable and he had
uh his wife i think
was named uh abby
cable and she was actually the niece
of anton the the super villain okay so
they just combined those two people into
one character
so at the beginning of the movie uh
there's this
top secret super secret government uh
research project going on out in these
[ __ ] swamps right
uh and one of the guys on the crew
has
presumably been eaten by an alligator
so adrian barbeau gets sent out there to
replace him
so out here at this secret facility
ray wise who's kind of like this genius
doctor and his sister who is also a
genius doctor are making this glowing uh
reanimator juice
it looks just like the reanimator juice
that's supposed to
well he's combining animal and plant dna
right and then it's supposed to just
make plants grow really fast to you know
stave off human starvation they're just
trying to grow more food for everybody
right
uh so there's that whole thing
now there's also this bad guy anton
arcane who's played by louis jordan uh
who was in octopussy actually a year or
two after this
he was a he was a bond villain keep
forgetting that this movie is that old
it is yeah yeah this came out when i was
10. yeah so damn that is old
but yeah so anton arcane also wants to
get his grubby little mitts on this uh
on this serum so he has hired uh this
gang of sort of idiotic militia dudes
to mercenaries yeah mercenaries to go in
there and like kind of get him out and
this and it's funny because it's uh the
little missionary the missionaries well
you know what i mean the the little
group is led by
david hess
who
is who obviously was krug in
uh last house on the left he always
plays a rapist he's very rapey in this
one too he doesn't actually rape anybody
that we know of but uh he threatens it a
couple times although adrian barbados
kicked him in the balls so there's that
uh but yeah so that's essentially what's
going on um you know the the militia not
militia guys why do i keep saying that's
different the the mercenary guys i just
keep it's it's an m word i just keep
saying yes
it's an m word so uh so the mercenary
guys keep trying to get in there and get
the serum and get the notebooks and all
this other [ __ ] and then it turns out a
bunch of people get killed and then ray
wise the doctor
he
spills the serum on himself and blows up
sets himself on fire well he doesn't you
know accidentally sets himself on fire
and then just jumps into the swamp
everybody thinks that he's dead
but then he comes back later
as swamp thing so the serum has made him
into this uh into this monster now at
first they want because i love ray wise
right like he he's been in a million
things um i'm my favorite is like twin
peaks obviously
but uh as leland palmer
but he was actually supposed to be
in the swamp thing suit too like at
least during the close-ups
but and then they were just gonna get a
stuntman for when swamp thing has to
like jump around but what happened was
when they did the makeup tests
the guy that plays swamp thing dick
durock which sounds like a comic book
name or a poem or a porn name too sorry
dick uh but
hopefully he probably already knows that
she's apologizing to the dude
nick hasn't done anything bad
i'm saying i'm sorry that his name
sounds like a poor man okay that's what
i've had all right
maybe he's maybe he's into that i don't
know uh but yeah so surprise stage name
yeah so when they did the makeup test
they were like well dick durock the
stuntman and ray wise look completely
different with that makeup on so
basically they're like okay well ray
wise just plays the human you know plays
his human equivalent and then once he's
in the suit it's gonna be the stuntman
like all the time
so that's kind of how they got around
that problem uh but you know so so as it
happens like the pretty much the whole
middle of the movie this isn't like a
very long movie i think it's only 93
minutes
uh that's with the titties added back in
i think it's only 91 minutes with the
titties taken out
but the whole middle of the movie is
essentially just adrian barbeau
trying to
run away from the mercenaries
uh and then she just keeps getting saved
by swamp thing like they keep capturing
her and then either she gets away or
swamp thing jumps up and like starts
beating the crap out of them yeah the
mercenaries are in there to be candid
fodder for swamp thing basically yeah he
just throws them around there's like
some air boat explosions it's pretty rad
i gotta say yeah i mean for a two i this
movie was actually better than i
remembered it's it's it's low budget you
can tell it's low budget
um it does have like some cool
explosions in it uh i do like the swamp
thing suit but it could have been a lot
better yeah uh the monster at the end
really kind of let it down i kind of
wish
i kind of wish that they would have just
let arcane
i kind of wish she hadn't even drunk the
serum you know what i mean
because
i mean you wouldn't have to show the
stupid ass mom then you wouldn't have to
show the stupid-ass monster like they
could have like written their way around
that because there was a thing where
so he see here's the dumb thing though
so anton arcane who's supposed to be
this big like evil super genius right
he sees what the serum did to
uh to swamp thing like he turned him
into swamp thing right to the doctor
and then he's like well just for shits
and giggles i'm gonna give it to one of
my henchmen like this big hulking dude
named bruno and it turns him into a
little person
who kind of looks like an elf or
something a pig man or a little pig man
or something
and uh he's like what the [ __ ] and then
that's when swamp thing says oh well the
serum i don't i'm not really sure how
swamp thing figured this out but he says
the serum actually just makes you more
of what you were to start with so you're
if you were
like kind of strong in heart or whatever
he didn't say this but this was how i
took it
um you know then it'll make you really
strong because swamp thing is really
super strong oh and also he has healing
abilities and can bring people back to
life yeah because a kid does get killed
in this
spoiler alert it is wes craven after all
he's like [ __ ] you i'm killing a kid but
uh but he gets brought back to life and
i think adrian barbeau gets killed a
couple of times yeah doesn't she get
killed a couple of times at least twice
she's drowned once and then the second
time that's right she got she got shot
by teddy yeah she got shot in the tip
that's right
at which point we were watching the
movie and i and i'm like taking on swamp
things voice being like honey you can't
just keep dying and like expecting me to
bring you back to life all the time this
is like the second time now right
now
like why she can't he fixes the titty
when she comes back they're actually
double g's
i said yeah that would because you would
that's right
i said that's what you would do if you
had swapped things
there you go
don't fall over
[Laughter]
yeah if she falls over her facial boy
she'll just like spring back up
but yeah so uh so yeah so he can bring
like [ __ ] back to life and everything so
i'm guessing that because the doctor was
like a good guy
um
he it turned him like physically
stronger and gave him healing abilities
whereas
the henchman and anton arcane were
[ __ ] although bruno was
okay i mean he did bad [ __ ] but you
could tell he felt sort of bad about it
you know what i mean so he was kind of
like a reluctant and then once he got
turned into a little pig person
um he turned on his
uh you know his superior pretty quickly
but see i think that really would have
made the movie if anton arcane okay okay
if they had to make him drink the serum
at least make him turn into something
that made sense yeah like i can't think
of anything right now like off the top
of my head but i'm sure
i can't sell
it's like i don't i don't know a pig
person with a mullet
and wearing like a just a beige
jumpsuit
how about that they could they could
have done anything other than what they
did
i mean i kind of thought well the first
thing i thought and i know they can't do
this because that would be ridiculous
that'd be a totally different kind of
movie i said well he you know he's
supposed to be like this big genius but
he's also like a huge giant like
arrogant [ __ ] i was like why don't
they just turn him into like a huge big
anus
but
i think what they should have done is
just turned him in it would have been so
much cheaper and more effective to turn
him into something more kind of like the
emperor from star wars just just an evil
sorcerer type you know they could have
done that
they could have done that that why don't
they give him like a reptilian type of
thing like a snake mod you know or
alligator or something like that more
just a [ __ ] a wizard costume like
yeah with some [ __ ]
uh uh reptile contact lenses and you
know a slight green hint tinge and maybe
he can [ __ ]
make some [ __ ] poison come out or
something just poisonous
i mean snake and alligator that would
have that would tie back to the swamp at
least so you'd at least have some
thematic like continuity at the end of
the movie it starts skewing very young
and childish they gotta have a monster
fights like something out of wwf wwe so
they wanted they wanted a monster he
could wrestle with that swamp thing be
throwing like you know throwing dudes at
a airport at airports air boats and like
blowing them up and [ __ ] like that
didn't quite know how to take
comic book movies
to the next level at this point they
they
they were still kind of tongue-in-cheek
you know what i mean they a little bit
they weren't taking their own
material seriously that was always the
[ __ ]
problem with comic book movies of of the
early era the people making it didn't
take the [ __ ] seriously so
you're gonna end up with [ __ ]
[ __ ] i mean you know i do like this
movie though it could have been better
but this is a very transitional this
wasn't only a transitional movie for
comic book movies in general it was also
a transitional movie for wes craven
because
as i said prior to this he had done more
kind of like gritty realistic uh super
violent horror films and then he did
this one
and this one did so badly that he
thought he wasn't gonna work again he
was actually kind of out of work for two
years he lost his house uh he had to
borrow money from sean cunningham for uh
you know from friday the 13th uh to pay
his taxes i think he borrowed five grand
from him or something and he just didn't
think he was going to work again but
while he was working on this movie he
had the idea for guess what nightmare on
elm street yeah so uh and obviously that
just like took the [ __ ] off so he went
on to do that and scream and everything
like that so it was fine but this was
definitely one that was like a
transitional and like i said it's one
when i talk about wes craven or when i
think about wes craven this is one that
i completely forgot that he directed
it's kind of like it's kind of like when
i think about john carpenter and
sometimes i completely forget that he uh
that he directed christine
you know what i mean it's one of the
even though i love that movie it's kind
of one of those things that you just
like forget because it's not one of
their big and it doesn't feel like a
carpenter movie that's huge that's true
i mean it kind of does a little bit but
um
yeah it's actually a little classier
than his normal [ __ ] in a certain way
i always say classier a little bit more
corporate feeling in a way like somebody
was keeping him under control
well i kind of feel like that's maybe
what happened with this movie too i just
i because swamp thing wasn't a proven
ip uh it was a comic book character that
was kind of like not a very well-known
one from the dc stable um there had
never really been a movie made of it
before wes craven had never made a movie
like this before uh it was a new
producer who had never worked in the
movie industry before so i kind of feel
like the other producers are the studio
was just kind of like man we're gonna
you know they really kind of wanted to
keep an eye over everything and they
were saying you know you got to cut this
you got to cut this you're spending too
much money and uh wes craven did not
really have a good experience on this
movie but
i mean taking all that into account it
still came out pretty decent i thought
and even though it didn't do very well
at the box office when it came out on
video it kind of became a cult hit so
much so that they made a sequel to it
that had um
uh dick dora came back
uh and louis jordan came back
and uh
the uh adrian barbara did not want to
come back so they put heather locklear
in it instead as the love interest
and then they also did a tv series uh
that i think went on for a couple
seasons and they did an animated like a
kids show although i think that only
lasted a few episodes but so it's
definitely
you know made a a cultural impact uh you
know what i mean just which is strange
like when you see this first movie
which is good but
you know considering like how much of a
cult following it has nowadays
swamp thing always swamp thing kind of
reminds it kind of feels like to me it
kind of feels like a
creep show like a creep show episode
it is a bit well and honestly it was
kind of well in creep show there was
that second one that had stephen king in
it the lonesome death of jordy verrell
where he turned into a plant person also
yeah so there was a lot of that [ __ ]
there's a lot of people turning into
plant and comic book classic comic book
movies in 1982. well creepy was a comic
book movie too yeah oh yeah creep you
know that was easy and
it kind of had that same tone and it had
a lot of the same effects it was just
more action oriented kind of like an
action movie from the 80s and i mean
creep show is dudes blowing up is much
much better than swamp thing uh i do
like swamp thing but creep show is like
a lot better
swamp thing has some of the comic book
stuff to it like that like the wipes
yeah uh or comic comic bookie like uh
like creep show had but it's not as
stylized i mean one of the best things
about creep shows that it looks like a
comic with those bright-ass colors and
all those like crazy backgrounds and
stuff like that this one doesn't have
that it's a lot more naturalistic if you
like if you like 80s action and you
liked creep show you'd probably like
this movie yeah it's a fun fun movie and
like i said if you you know if you
always wanted to see adrien barbeau's
tits yeah you want to see that version
that's something you want to see the
version the version that's on to me does
have all the titties all does have all
the nudity pretty impressive
and like i said i do like well you know
not too much today i mean all these
girls are [ __ ] had got huge [ __ ]
cans and [ __ ] a lot of implants i
mean you know it's just everywhere now
but back in those days you know
just well you had to take what you could
get you could take what you could get
you know
porn was difficult to get you know
especially you couldn't just get it
delivered to you over a phone carrying
your phone around your pocket that [ __ ]
didn't exist back then either
so yeah you had to find some find some
playboys in the woods yes
or hope for a little glimpse or yeah or
try to like see stuff like would you
know you had all the all the playboy
channel and stuff that was all like
scrambled on your cable box and you had
to like just watch and it's like oh i
think i see a nipple yeah it was it was
that yeah
i remember those [ __ ] channels yeah i
do too yeah we're all scrambled mm-hmm
but every now and then you could kind of
see something yeah like straight down
for a few seconds every now and then
yeah
this one's just during a commercial
though
oh my god but yeah so uh yeah tell tell
tell us what you think about uh swamp
thing one of wes craven's lesser talked
about movies i guess even though it's
actually a perfectly enjoyable 80s uh
monster movie kind of fun uh you know
could have done with some better special
effects but that's okay i still had a
good time watching it uh so yeah that'll
do it for this movie retrospective we'll
see you guys on the next one bye
you